في مقابله العمل طرح الاسئله على مسؤول
التوظيف لا يميزك عن المرشحين الاخرين في
حسب بل يساعدك على تحديد ما اذا كنت ستكون
سعيدا في عملك الجديد ام لا في البدايه
يمكن توجيه هذا السؤال بثقه هل اجبت على
جميع اسئلتك او هل تريد مني توضيح اي شيء
قلته او انت قراته في سيرتي الذاتيه ومن
ثم اسال عن المشاكل او التحديات التي
تواجهها الشركه وما الخطوات المتبعه
للتقدم على ابرز المنافسين لها وكيف لي ان
اسهم في تقدم الشركه من اهم الاسئله التي
عرضها تقرير وكاله بلومبيرج ايضا هي عن
سياسه العمل من المنزل وما اذا كانت الفرص
والاجور متساويه للموظفين الذين يعملون عن
بعد والذين يعملون من المكتب ايضا من
حقيقه السؤال حول كيفيه تقييم الاداء
ومعرفه قياس الشركه لنجاح موظفيها ولكن
تجنب السؤال عن ايام الاجازات ولا تتحدث
عن الراتب حتى المراحل الاخيره في
المقابله والافضل انتظار العرض الذي سيقدم
من قبلهم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات